Paris's new Russian Orthodox Holy
Trinity Cathedral stands tall on the
banks of the Sun close to the Eiffel
Tower after nine years of diplomatic
haggling it was consecrated with much
pomp and circumstance by patriarch Kiro
of Moscow with French representatives in
attendance Daniels Tova's parents fled
to Paris because of their faith his
grandfather had run afoul of Vladimir
Lenin's Bolsheviks and had to leave the
Soviet Union
stiva isn't drawn to the Russian state
Orthodox Church he feels more at home in
this Western oriented Orthodox
congregation in a purist courtyard for
what consider me as a child of Russian
emigre I wasn't able to travel to the
Soviet Union
so my tie to Russia has been this church
here that was built by immigrants
the icons were painted by defectors from
Joseph Stalin's regime hundreds of them
came to France and made Paris a
spiritual hub of the Western oriented
Orthodox faith
and France welcomed the most highly
educated immigrants with open arms
Orthodox Christians have about 30 houses
of worship around the French capital and
another cathedral so Suva insists a new
one isn't really needed I was opposed to
a Cathedral that would be entirely
financed and maintained by funding from
the Russian government is a problem for
us it'll be used to apply ideological
and political pressure on the Orthodox
parishes in France and we don't want
that
it was France's ex President Nicolas
Sarkozy who approved construction of the
Cathedral in the inner city in contrast
to the Russian embassy which is further
away from the center and later it wasn't
politically expedient for president
Francois Hollande to stop the project
the Russians and the French did each
other favors the Russians placed orders
for mr. Carla class wharfs which created
jobs at the troubled shipyards and
sunnahs air in return the French
accepted the status of a diplomatic
building for the Russian Cathedral which
is not at all normal for some years now
the patriarch of Moscow has claimed
authority over the ecclesiastical
buildings of the western-oriented
Orthodox congregations in all of France
saying they were built with Russian
money but there's opposition especially
in Paris critics say the church
buildings were actually largely financed
by private donations
Luther says this is well documented
we're actually lucky Putin wasn't more
subtle about it so that would have been
far more dangerous for our congregations
descendants of the immigrants who dran
form to this new Russia have to work out
for themselves where they stand
and what they want this addition of all
the [ __ ] sister worshippers in the
Western oriented Orthodox Church aren't
all ethnic Russians many non Russian
French have also joined and they stand
behind the priests who refuse to
disseminate any political content
reflecting Russian president Putin's
interests these congregations have long
been a thorn in the side of the Russian
Orthodox Church there are so many great
thinkers in Paris but some of them have
obscured the Word of God and have even
spoken disdainfully of God because
they've been so blinded by human ideas
that view also receives support in
France the russian french cultural
society extolled the virtues of the new
cathedral as it's great we always had to
apply for grants from the city of paris
we don't have that kind of money or
ourselves now we are getting space for
our events for free i don't have to pay
anything at all you can see people as
that's all to Daniel's Tuva the price
for returning to the Russian state
churches fold is too high and there's
the family tradition his father was a
well-known publisher in Paris and the
first to print Aleksandr Solzhenitsyn's
Gulag Archipelago a detailed exposure of
Soviet labor camps that put one of the
first cracks and the foundation of the
Soviet Union the family conducted an
intensive discussion of Christianity
with the dissident means freedom that's
one of the few commandments of the New
Testament but the idea of freedom
especially in religious questions is
quite a problem in today's Russia that's
why I've got the impression that we
haven't yet completed our mission here
from exile to VA's family once stood up
for freedom of worship in the Soviet
Union now he sees his mission as
unchanged but the battlefield
come home to Paris